[Music]
foreign
so I'm pretty excited about this lecture
because we are going to introduce one of
the Workhorse numerical integration
algorithms the runga Cutta integrators
to simulate a non-linear system of
differential equations x dot equals f of
x comma t
so we've been talking about differential
equations dynamical systems systems that
vary that vary in time that change in
time things like a pendulum swinging or
spring Mass damper or the population of
animals or you know particle floating in
the Gulf of Mexico something like that
and most of the time we have to simulate
these differential equations we can't
write them out the solution by hand
using analytic techniques we can only do
that for linear differential equations
there's only kind of General
one-size-fits-all solutions for linear
differential equations
but for generic non-linear differential
equations like this we typically have to
resort to numerical integration of a
trajectory in time
and so
about Euler schemes forward Euler and
backward Oiler which are like the
quickest dirtiest numerical integrators
you could cook up by using a finite
difference approximation of this
derivative and seeing what happens those
are really easy and nice to analyze
things like stability proper properties
and error analysis but they're really
kind of crummy integrators and so today
I'm going to introduce the runga Cutta
integration schemes in particular the
second order and fourth order runga
Cutta schemes which are way more
accurate and really are kind of these
Workhorse numerical integration
algorithms so if you just use kind of a
off-the-shelf integrator there's a good
chance it's a runga cut a scheme and
it's going to work most of the time for
most of the systems I care about now
there are absolutely exceptions for
certain very chaotic systems this might
not work for stochastic differential
equations this isn't going to work and
for really really stiff differential
equations that have very very different
time scales in the problem for each of
those cases we'll need different
integrators that I'll talk about later
but today I'm going to introduce this uh
this runga Cutta scheme and so I'm
actually going to start by just writing
up
what our forward Euler scheme was
because that's kind of like the zeroth
order or first order rangakata scheme
and it's a piece that I'm going to use
in these schemes so just to remind you
our forward
Euler
or Fe scheme if I want to integrate this
I'm going to say that
um
X at time step K plus 1 is equal to X at
time step k
plus a little delta T whatever my time
step delta T is times my function f
evaluated at x k comma TK at the the
teeth time step
um
and that position x k my current K
position x k
and again we analyze this we derive this
from scratch we looked at the error and
stability properties it's easy to
analyze but it's a very poor integrator
and so today I'm going to introduce this
runga cutter scheme and I'm going to
start off with runga cut a second order
an rk2 scheme I'm going to draw a
picture and show you how it works how
intuitively you can think of this scheme
and then I'm going to write down the
fourth order runga cut a scheme so um
let's say runga
second order
which I'm going to call rk2
okay our rk2 scheme and I'm just going
to write this down we're going to write
this down that uh
x k plus 1
is similarly we always start with the
current so we're trying to step from
time step K to K plus 1 so we're at x k
and we're trying to go to x k plus one
so let me I'll draw a picture here we
have some trajectory
and this is my XK position and I'm
trying to predict where is my system
going to be at the next time step x k
plus 1 where x k is literally my
trajectory at time step my case time
step which is usually K delta T
and so we're trying to predict this x k
plus 1 only using information from XK
and so we always start with this x k
position so it always starts with x k
and then we update we figure out what is
the step I need to take what x k plus
what gets me to this next point and so
in rk2 this is plus delta T
times my function
my Vector field my right hand side of my
ordinary differential equation evaluated
at
um
x k
plus delta T over 2 f of x k t k
I'm going to explain this in a minute
I'm going to write it all out then I'm
going to explain it
comma TK
plus delta T over 2.
okay uh did I get all my parentheses I
got all my parentheses and notice here
that this this right hand side function
f of x comma T this because I said comma
T what that means is that my right hand
side Vector field my my right hand side
of my differential equation can be
varying in time and so the example I
have been giving in the past is maybe
I'll make my Vector field blue and I'll
make my land green so let's say I have
my Gulf of Mexico Vector field I like to
think about you know fluid flow Fields
as the Specter field in two dimensions
and again let's say that I have this
kind of vector field
um
I'm just going to draw a couple of
arrows this is my function f and and
what that means is that at every point x
at all of these points X spatially there
is some some Vector F this is you know a
vector State X and a vector field F then
in this case it has two components an X
Direction and a y direction so this
Vector F tells me how much my position
of my particle changes in time so if I
drop a little particle here and I take a
little DT step forward my Vector field
is pointing in this direction and so my
particle is going to move
infinitesimally in that direction and
trace a trajectory okay this kind of
trajectory here
and so because I have f of x comma T
what that means is that these blue
arrows can actually be changing in time
of course the flow field and the actual
Gulf of Mexico does change in time so
this is a very realistic assumption here
not just to have x dot equals f of x but
to have f of x comma T to have this
Vector field changing in time
and so I'm writing this down generic
case of a Time varying Vector field here
and if this Vector field doesn't change
in time then you can just ignore all of
these comma T terms uh and just apply
this to your stationary Vector field f
of x
okay so we're going to interpret this
messy expression maybe what I'm going to
do first is write down an alternative
way to write this another way to write
this is uh or let's write or alternative
an alternative
is to write uh x k plus one
equals x k plus delta T times sum F2
vector
where we Define F2 in the following way
we say uh F1
is this Vector field is f of x k comma
TK
and F2
is f of
uh x k
plus delta T over 2
F1 comma TK
plus delta T over 2.
this is a lot of math I just wrote down
now I'm going to explain exactly how you
can code this up and how to interpret
this second order runga code scheme it's
actually extremely extremely simple the
idea here is
again our our x k plus one the next step
in our trajectory is going to start with
the current step of our trajectory so
you know let's say that this is x k this
current step right here this is our
current position right here
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take a delta T step in a
direction F2 F2 is going to be a vector
that we're going to decide on we're
going to take a delta T step in the F2
Direction actually just like forward
Euler we took a delta T step uh in the
in the vector field Direction in the F
Direction at x k t k in rk2 we're also
going to take a delta T step but in this
new F2 Direction and I'm going to tell
you how to get that F2 direction now
so the first thing we do
is we look at the point we're at right
now at the XK location and we find what
is this Vector uh what is the vector at
XK at time TK and this is literally this
Vector here that I've drawn in Blue uh
is my f 1 Vector okay so the the arrow
pointing out the the vector field at
time t k and at point x k is my F1 and
forward Euler would stop there it would
literally take uh you know x k plus
delta T F1 that's what forward Euler
would do is it would take this F1 and it
would just take a big delta T step in
that direction that's what forward Euler
would do but that's kind of inaccurate
we know that's not a very good
approximation and so what rangakatta
does is very clever it takes a half step
it takes a half step
a half delta T a delta T over two step
in the F1 Direction so it takes a half
step in this direction
and then it queries what is the vector
field at that position and that half
time step later so it queries the vector
field it literally says you know it
takes a half step forward to XK plus
delta T over 2 F1 so a half Euler step
then it queries the vector field and
says what is the vector Direction at
that point at that half step location
maybe I'll draw that kind of in this
dashed orange and maybe the vector field
has changed a little bit maybe it's it's
rotated a little bit at this point and
it's pointing in a slightly different
direction so this is the F two point
and then what forward what what the
second order rangakuta scheme does is it
takes a full Euler step starting from my
XK position but now in this F2 Direction
so it takes a full Euler step a full
delta T Oiler step
starting from XK so a full Euler step
starting from XK but in this F2
Direction okay and this is X K plus 1
forward Euler and you'll see that this
actually is doing a better job because
it's kind of taking into account the
fact that if my Vector field is slowly
kind of turning around or changing or I
have some curvature that F2 Vector is
going to capture that information and
I'm going to take a better step
using using this so I'm going to try to
draw a picture and then and then then
restate what I just said
so if I have some curve that's going
around like this
naive forward Euler thing to do would be
to take this Vector field maybe it's
pointing in in this direction
is to take the vector field and take a
full Euler step in that direction that's
what the forward Euler naive thing to do
is but what run
in that that that Vector field Direction
then it queries the vector field at that
half step and now maybe that's pointing
in a different direction like this this
is my F2
this is my F1 and then the final thing
it does is it takes a full Euler step in
that new F2 Direction starting from my
base point
so that would be here
and the way I drew it it almost
perfectly works out so this is XK this
is X K plus one it would almost
perfectly work out to actually be on the
trajectory so the forward Euler is only
getting the tangent Direction and so
it's going to kind of leave this curved
trajectory manifold whereas querying in
the half point and then using that
direction
corrects for the effect of at least
second order curvature second
derivatives in my trajectory and so the
way I drew this my forward Euler step
sorry my runga cutter 2 my rk2 step is
almost perfectly Landing back on that
trajectory whereas forward Euler had
this large error and inaccuracy here
here this pink curve is my my true
trajectory
okay good so it's actually really really
simple and I'll I'll decode it again I
think it's it's helpful for me to say
this a few times because this can be a
little confusing but it's actually
really not that bad the first thing we
do in in rk2 is that we essentially look
at the vector field
at my base point so this is the vector
field at base point
okay F2 means we take a half step so you
can convince yourself that the arguments
here this literally is a half Euler step
this is a half
forward Euler step
in the F1 Direction
so we we take
half step
in F1 Direction
and we essentially query the vector
field to get F2 and
query
the vector field you know to get F2 to
get this F2 and then once we have this
F2 we take a full Euler step we take a
full Euler step
so this is a full forward Euler step
but now in the F2 this better F2
Direction and that's all there is to it
that's the second order I'm going to cut
a scheme it's actually really simple and
you can imagine coding this up in python
or Matlab it's almost trivial if we have
access to this function f and we know
what x k is I can compute F1 I literally
call f of x k comma TK and I get this F1
Vector no big deal I have F1 and once I
have F1 I can compute F2 I know my
Vector field and I can query my Vector
field at this x k plus delta T over 2f1
this half Euler step at this new time TK
plus delta T over 2.
and once I have F2 I can compute my next
full update XK plus one using this
formula here so this is really simple
it's actually almost identical it can
kind of be built on top of the same
infrastructure you have to compute these
forward Euler steps and instead of
acquiring your vector field or Computing
this f of x comma T only a single time
in forward Euler here we're Computing it
twice so this is going to be twice as
expensive as forward Euler because I'm
doing two function evaluations but it's
way more than twice as accurate so I'm
going to need less time steps for runga
Cutta than than Euler so it's still a
really good idea to do this even though
it's twice as expensive per delta T I
can get away with a much larger delta T
here because it's way way way more
accurate okay
and So speaking of accuracy
um maybe in another lecture I'll
actually derive using the Taylor series
The accuracy of this algorithm you would
literally you know expand out this F in
powers of delta T here and it's not so
bad you can totally do this it's just a
little bit of a hairy
um 2D
Taylor series example you could totally
do this
um
I don't think it's super duper
enlightening it's just a very like
detailed derivation if you're very
careful you can expand this out and
compute the error and what you'll find
is that the error
uh the local error at least the error is
kind of locally
order
delta T cubed every time step
and that's way better than my forward
Euler which was Delta t squared every
time step so this is a much more
accurate algorithm every time step this
is is order delta T cubed that's what we
call our local error and because errors
compound every step you take you're
adding more and more and more error and
if I make delta T smaller I have to take
1 over a delta T steps so my Global
error is this number divided by delta T
so my Global error
my error is globally order uh Delta t
squared over entire trajectory
which is where the name rk2 comes from
it's a second order runga cut a scheme
meaning it's second order Global
accuracy now global error is a little
bit misleading because if I have a
chaotic system each of these little
local errors is actually going to grow
exponentially in forward time so the
global error is not something you can
really rely on but it's still a useful
kind of quantity to keep track of is is
um you know how much error would accrue
in a non-chaotic system that's This
Global Delta t squared error
uh good and I hope you can convince
yourself here in this expression um that
this is exactly what I wrote down kind
of broken down into these three steps so
this
is equivalent to this where again we
take a full delta T step in the F2
Direction Where F2 is f
evaluated at a half
a half Euler step
okay so that that's literally F
evaluated at a half Euler step and then
I take a full step in that direction
starting from my base point x k
so really really easy to to cook this up
you could even derive there's actually a
family of second order around get cutter
schemes which I think is kind of cool
um you could derive like for example if
you put a constant
p and Q you know P you could play around
with this and you could derive different
schemes that would also have similar
accuracy I like this one because these
half steps are really easy to code up
and it also allows you to write an
Adaptive algorithm you could actually
um
use information so so the built-in codes
in in Python and in Matlab actually are
rk23 algorithms and rk45 algorithms they
use an Adaptive step so if they think
that their error is acceptably small
they will double the time step until the
error creeps up and if they think that
the error is too large they will have
the time steps to some limit so that
they're always taking kind of the right
time step for the problem based on the
curvatures of these trajectories okay
that's kind of a cool detail
um okay so that's our K2 this is the rk2
algorithm and I actually like it in this
form here because it's way easier to
understand kind of what's what's
happening uh when you write it out like
this so I think what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to erase some stuff clean
up the board and then I'm going to write
down what is the fourth order runga cut
a scheme and in the next lecture we're
going to code up that fourth order runga
cut a scheme and simulate something
chaotic like the Lorenz 63 system okay
so I'm going to erase just one second
Okay so we've written down and analyzed
and kind of decomposed and dissected the
second order runkakata scheme which is a
very good algorithm considerably better
than forward Euler now I'm going to
write down the fourth order rangakata
scheme which again that's the one I
always use first when you know if I
don't know what kind of problem I'm
dealing with I'll usually use a fourth
order runga credit scheme so I'm going
to write it down and then just like this
we're going to analyze it okay so the
fourth order runga cut a scheme I'm just
going to
um I'm actually just gonna write it down
so we have x k plus 1
equals x k and now it's not going to be
as simple as just taking a full Euler
step in a new F2 Direction I'm gonna
have to take a like some weird average
of a bunch of different Vector
directions and take a full Euler step in
that weird average Direction
so it's uh plus delta T over 6. times an
F1 Direction plus two of another F2
Direction plus two F of the F3 Direction
plus one of the F4 Direction
so again this is an average because
there's one plus two plus two plus one
is six so I'm taking the average of
these four directions these four Vector
directions and then I'm taking a big
delta T Euler step in that weird average
Direction where these F1 F2 F3 f4s are
defined the following way
where
F1 is just my normal
my normal you know first Vector like I
query F at this point at this point in
time and space and I get F1 so F1 didn't
change that's just
f of x k comma t k
at time k
now F2 is similarly just like before F2
is uh the same F2 nothing changed
F2 is my
um
function evaluated at a half Euler step
later okay this is uh F at x k plus
delta T over 2 times F1 evaluated at T K
plus delta T over 2. I just want to make
sure I I get this 100 right because this
is really important and it'll mess me up
later if I don't this is correct so F1
and F2 actually haven't changed it's the
same first two steps of four of uh runga
cut it two
but now F3 and F4 is where it starts
getting interesting so F3 now what I do
is now that I have this F2 Direction now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take a half step in that F2 Direction
okay so I'm going to take a half step in
I'm pretty sure I'm going to take a half
step in the F2 Direction so this is now
going to be a half step in the F2
Direction and that's going to give me
another
Vector F3 okay so F3 is going to be f of
x k plus a half step
in the F2 Direction TK plus delta T over
2 and then finally F 4 is going to be
taking a full step in this F3 Direction
and evaluating the vector field there so
F4
equals f
of x k
plus delta T F3
comma
TK plus delta T
okay I want to make sure I got this
right I take a Okay so
and this is kind of gnarly so then what
I do is I take this F3 Direction I take
a full Euler step in that direction to
get here maybe I'll put this in uh
yellow even though it's gonna be hard to
see and then I take a full Euler step in
that direction to get F4 so I I sorry I
don't take a full Euler step yeah I take
a full Euler step in the F3 Direction
and evaluate my Vector field at that new
location to get F4 and so rk4 is a weird
algorithm like why on Earth would you do
all of these things and then add them up
in this mixture to get this update well
the answer is basically Taylor series if
you write out the Taylor series of all
of these terms and add them up in
exactly this
this uh proportion what you'll find is
that you actually cancel out the error
to an outrageously high order of Delta
Theta delta T to the fifth so this is an
order
um
this is order delta T to the fifth local
and Order delta T to the fourth Global
accuracy
for our this is our rk4 scheme and so
it's essentially you know these were
custom designed all of these weird steps
in designing you know F3 and F4 and
taking this combination is designed
specifically to cancel out error in this
Taylor series expansion so you're you're
driving your error term out to a higher
order in delta T so it's in this case
order delta T to the fifth so this
algorithm is way better than rangakuta's
second order and way better than forward
Euler okay and again you can interpret
all of these in exactly the same way so
just like before you know Step One is
um
you know get your normal Vector field
Direction starting from your base point
so this is Vector field at
base point
the next step is evaluate Vector field
after half Euler step so evaluate
Vector field after
half forward Euler
in F1
F3 is similar so you know if that was a
good idea to take a half step in in F1
and query to get F2 now what we're going
to do is we're going to take a half step
in F2 and query to get F3
so evaluate
Vector field after
half forward Euler
in F2
and then finally F4 is you know evaluate
Vector field after
full
forward Euler step
in
F3 and the idea is none of these
directions are perfect none of those are
perfectly going to get you exactly where
you need to go on the on the trajectory
but this average here if I take one in
the F1 Direction and two in the F2
Direction and two in the F3 Direction
and one in the F4 Direction
and then I average those I take that
that mean by dividing by six by adding
those up and dividing by six that
direction I can take a forward Euler
step in and it gives me order delta T to
the fifth local error very very cool um
and you could derive this this would
take a bunch of of glass boards to
derive this honestly doing the error
analysis for the second order runga
credit probably is going to take me one
or two full boards just to get this
error analysis this one's pretty pretty
uh hairy but it works like a charm so
you don't need to derive why it's all of
these constants exactly you just need to
understand what your algorithm is doing
and again these are easy to do if I have
access to this Vector field if it's a
function on my computer I can query then
it's really easy for me to evaluate here
then use that F1 to evaluate here then
use that F2 to evaluate here and then
use that F3 to evaluate here so we're
going to code this up in Python and in
Matlab we're going to use this to
integrate the trajectory of an
interesting pretty challenging system
the chaotic Lorenz 1960 E3 system
okay what other things do I want to tell
you
um
you know what's interesting if you think
about it
forward Oiler could almost be considered
like an arcade first order scheme so
it's almost like forward Oiler is a
first order runga kind of scheme and
then the second order runga Keta scheme
is using this half step to get a higher
order accuracy this order Delta cubed
locally instead of order Delta squared
locally and then this fourth order
rangakuta is taking more kind of half
steps and full steps is doing more
queries of the vector field to get an
even higher accurate scheme so again
this is going to be four times more
expensive than forward Oiler and it's
going to be twice as expensive as rk2
but it's so much more accurate that you
can get away with a much larger delta T
at the same accuracy and this is so this
is still way way way more efficient and
accurate uh on a kind of per accuracy
basis
anything else I want to say I guess the
reason that you can you can actually
reason through why
the coefficients out here are one two
two one if you think about it this F1
Direction was a full Euler step which is
you know the bigger the step the more
you're probably introducing inaccuracy
is because that big delta T is
inaccurate F4 was also a full Euler step
in the F3 direction to get that Vector
field we took a full Euler step to get
F4 but F2 and F three we only took half
Euler steps to get the F2 and the F3
directions and so those are probably a
little more accurate and those can be
multiplied by two because those are half
steps at least that's how I think about
it is that when I want to weight these
things I'm going to wait my little half
steps you know twice as much because I
trust them more they're kind of my
interior estimates and then these outer
estimates that were full Euler steps I
trust them less so I'm going to weight
them less and then that's why I add them
up and divide by six
okay good uh so yeah we're going to code
this up we're going to run this
integrator we're going to see how it
performs and then we're going to look at
chaotic systems I'll probably tell you a
little bit more about those other types
of integrators for stochastic systems
for stiff systems for chaotic systems
later but for now you can think of this
rk4 as kind of your Workhorse go-to
algorithm and again it's built into most
modern computational
software like Matlab or Python and numpy
okay uh great thank you
[Music]